i believe that companies today are
looking towards
cloud technology to shore up their
business value at the end of the day
hello my name is jerry stark i'm an i.t
professional from louisville kentucky
back in april i was laid off from a
company i'd been working for for 10 plus
years and i felt like it was important
for me to
gain some more knowledge in the i.t
space and
come up to date with the latest
technologies when i was out there
searching for
a right organization for me at the end
of the day
i chose simply learn because they not
only had the
self-learning videos but they also had
the live classes and the virtual lab
to go along with it so it was at the end
of the day it was a no-brainer for me
thus far i've taken two classes from
simply learn i took the aws
solutions architect associates class and
also took the microsoft azure
fundamentals class however transversing
the aws
class i always had the perfect blend of
live classes versus self
learning videos doing the lab work i was
able to take
book knowledge and equate it to hands-on
knowledge so i was able to get some
hands-on experience with the product
as i was going through the class and
that really helped understand and shore
up my understanding
of the technology lifelong learning is
important to me because
it helps me keep up to date on the
latest i.t
technologies plus it also shows that i
have
the ability to learn and i think that
continuing education is very very
important
for any corporation i believe that their
employees
that continue to do continuing education
and learn
all the new aspects of it seem to
migrate towards a better job and so
therefore
at the end of the day i wanted to
basically take this technology
and learn it to the point where i could
be a consultant to
a corporation that needed to migrate to
the cloud
i would highly recommend simply learn to
my friends and colleagues
i have enjoyed my experience thus far
and the support that i'm getting from
the support team at
simply learn is is unmatched with any
other support that i've gotten
in fact i had a few issues along the way
connecting up with the
virtual lab and i sent in a ticket
to the service desk and simply learn
responded immediately and took care of
my issue within 24 hours
my family is very dear to me and they
have been so supportive
of my efforts in this class these
classes can take
you know they take anywhere from two to
four hours of class work and then you
have
your study time afterwards so i spend
probably four to six hours a day
studying and my family has really really
been so supportive of me and
that has been so so good for me